your whole outfit doesn't make any sense
you look like a Disney Channel version
of Slave Leia meaning I'm only 1/8
[Music]
[Laughter]
hard my bracelets are so strong they can
stop bullets F would shoots you at that
Hot Zone the human wrist while I'm here
usually do it at the end but I'm going
to mix it up wow yeah
wow and you can't fire me I'm the only
woman it would be a PR nightmare I
actually thought about that see women
are all like treat us equal so if I
don't fire you and I'm firing everyone
else that actually makes me a non
feminist I do not think you get to
decide if you're a feminist no no let me
B play expain this to you you're a lady
mhm no need you no
more finish the sentence no need you no
more sweetie let me Bain what sexism is
to you real quick when a man pretends to
trust a woman oh wow let me put this in
terms a woman will understand oh that's
offensive when a cake is done and your
husband is hungry take it out then bring
it to him but then come back in the
kitchen while he eats
it no [__] sense I love it you know
yeah there's not even a logic do it I am
Princess Diana from the mascara you mean
that hot lesbian island with horses
right do they ever get in the
mix I'm so
sorry that's the line that's the
one you took the time to add ears to
your helmet so my ear is here and I'm
wearing hearing aids and these are like
little am antennas sometimes I pick up
wait wait don't tell me ball of pound
Stone you devil how did you think of
that so quickly
in your corduroy
blazer that was good that's my demograph
oh NPR joke come on the
floor what are your deepest darkest
secrets please no I don't even know what
a bad is some kind of Raven does it
sound right I don't brush my teeth but I
do run my toothbrush under the faucet to
fool Alfred he's always checking on me
I'm like hello my parents are dead let
my mouth bones rot you British
[__] sometimes I look at my butthole in
the mirror just to check in check what
just you know anything new going
on I have a deeper secret identity [__]
dick Daniels except when I put on a fake
beard and go to open mics and do prop
comedy under the name Gary gesp what's
Gary got in his bag of tricks today a SL
side whistle that's also a
dildo they're all also
[Music]
dildos